[Musique]
ça va ou quoi alors comme ça on apprécie
les anecdotes un des anecdotes pas reçus
deux anecdotes par là mais ça n'en finit
plus que les amis j'ai puisé dans les
fins fonds de mon cerveau pour me
souvenir de truc que j'avais vraiment
oublié à la base vraiment c'est fou
youtube fait de moi un surhomme
aujourd'hui les amis il ya du gore il ya
du mignon ya du rigolo bref tous les
adjectifs sont employables face à ce que
vous avez écouté et war êtes vous prêts
oui les amis c'est tout ce que cf en cm2
d'avoir onze d'avoir son premier poil de
domination on en est fiers plus fier
qu'à 20 sur 20 ne nous mentons pas mais
quand ce poils poussent ils te dis alors
moi j'avais trouvé ma dulcinée elle
était sexy raffinés comme dirait
l'artiste mais un autre homme était sur
elle si je puis me permettre un autre
enfant plutôt et il s'appelait alexandre
alexandre braga cette fille à la cour de
récréation et moi caché tamisée dans
l'ombre je voyais cela sous mes yeux ça
me rendait très énervé de plus j'étais
très triste pendant les heures de cours
pourquoi car il était dans sa classe et
moi pas bref après six mois de galère je
sors avec cette vie c'est à dire qu'on
se tient la main pendant les semaines à
et pendant les semaines br tient la main
de cet autre personne que j'emmerde tout
faisant son passé mais rien n'a changé
sur ce que je ressens roquettes
bon plus le temps passe plus elle oublie
ça trois individus pour penser à moi à
la place il est vrai on s'envoie des
wizz sur msn il est vrai j'ai la chance
d'habiter pas trop loin de chez elle et
on rentre ensembles de l'école il est
vrai elle commence à m'inviter chez elle
petit à petit il est vrai j'ai 15 ans à
ce moment là donc non on va pas baiser
c'est bon arrêté mais lorsqu'on a onze
années on est dans la recherche du snack
je parle pas du cirque
je suis chez ma dulcinée lorsqu elle
m'invite à monter au premier étage
sachant une fois là-haut je suis à la
fois très heureux et à la fois
complètement paniqué mais ces deux
sentiments qui ne vont pas du tout
ensemble parce qu'il crée tout
simplement un état de paralysie comme
s'il y avait un mauvais ça on s'assoit
tous les deux sur son lit arrêtez de
croire qui va se passer les choses
regarde tous les deux en face de nous et
on ne reste pas regarder elle décide de
faire le premier pas bon après ce
premier pas il est pas ou failli
s'appeler audrey audrey surya cette
vidéo ton premier pas il était pas ouf
dans mes cochons à claire elle marche
vers son bureau qui est en face de nous
elle y trouve des post it
elle prend un stylo elle écrit sur ce
post it puis elle revient s'asseoir à
côté de moi moi je suis toujours
paralysie à ce moment-là à certains sont
dans leur jacuzzi moi je suis dans ma
paralysie ok mais la vraie paralysie
après m'être pris 18 coups de coude dans
les côtes je comprends que ce qu'elle a
écrit sur ce post it ça m'est destinée
alors je me lève toujours dans la
paralysie
ce qui donne quelque chose comme ça je
prends le post-it dans mes petits doigts
d'enfants très doux et génie lui qu'un
vieux
gfr
hoballah mon coeur mon pote iv on est
sur un beat africain j'écris sur le
deuxième post it la chose suivante si
audrey voilà ce classement lavandin cage
thoracique voilà je retourne s'asseoir à
côté donnerai toujours sans la regarder
on est là pour embrasser un post it à la
fin la broderie on s'en fout on n'a pas
les couilles
hélas après trois minutes elle se décide
à aller voir ce que j'ai puis elle
revient
attention sans avoir écrit quoi que ce
soit à quoi tu joues audrey la petite
goutte de sueur sur l'attend peut-être
été préféré que je lui dise moi je
t'aime pas mais star fulham mais ce
n'est pas le cas qu'a fait pas ton
boulot ça elle crée tu veux la smat
et/ou en [ __ ] mais le conseil du poil
mec je vais sur le post it comme ça je
suis des terres je sors mon stylo en
mode ira de death note et je note la
chose suivante on s'embrasse pour un
interrogations faux lui se retire l'euro
au montage que hélas elle se retourne
vers moi et elle fait ça
cet instant dur à la fois une seconde
est à la fois dit milanais je n'ai que
très peu de temps pour prendre une
décision et je prends la meilleure
décision qui soit
[Musique]
c'était le premier smac de ma vie ces
derniers mais c'est la fin de cette
première anecdote j'espère qu'elle vous
a plu je voulais vous raconter ça parce
que je trouve que c'est important la
première fois on a osé faire un bisou à
une fille et moi je suis content parce
que ça s'est passé de la manière la plus
mignonne qui soit on les diminue rendre
il faut se dire j'espère qu'après ça tu
as trouvé l'amour de ta vie et qu'il a
fait sa demande en mariage en écrivant
sur des post-it
olala ça critique et tout alors ça a
cliqué mais comment ça s'est passé vous
ont le plus besoin qu'une fille bâtiment
aux commentaires j'épingle aurait le
meilleur envol et j'espère que c'est
bien passé pour vous peut importe la
technique vous avez eu moi c'était les
post-it y en a c'est peut-être la
feuille a4 ou la direction allait cash
et qui ont fini au commissariat car la
fille n'était pas consentante un bref
c'est le monde la deuxième anecdote qui
est tout l'inversé de la première à
savoir elle n'est pas glamour du tout
aller dégueuler horrible je les ai déjà
dit plusieurs fois mais je le répète
quand j'étais plus jeune j'allais au
week end sur deux chez bon papa cette
année là j'avais 12 ans vous savez très
bien quoi je ressemblais à 12 ans on l'a
vu la dernière fois ensemble je portais
les costumes cravates trop grand comme
actuellement et on avait mangé des noix
de saint jacques avec mon papa et puis
j'étais allé me coucher vers minuit à
3h30 du matin j'ouvre les yeux je me
sens mal très mal je sent la sueur
coulait le long de ma temps je me dis
hou là là il y a un problème je me lève
de mon lit et l'âge et le besoin
d'évacuer ce qui pose problème à mon
corps c'est une manière polie pour dire
que je begert sa mère sur la moquette
mon gars mais vraiment puissant là je
prends conscience que je suis
probablement en train de faire une
indigestion cas un début de guerre
trouver un truc qui va parler pendant
que je prends conscience de ça mon
intestin mfs prennent conscience
d'autres choses du fait qu'elles ont
besoin elles aussi d'évacuer mais elle
me préviennent pas alors pendant que je
vomis je me chinois c'est bon je les dis
c'est pas ce moment terrible ça arrive
très peu de fois dans une vie après 12
ans mais quand ça arrive tu as un somme
incroyable je me dirige alors aux
toilettes ont vérifié si ce qui vient
d'arriver est vraiment arrivé au cas où
il c'est arrivé je vais alors dans la
salle de bain et je retire mon caleçon
pour le nettoyer étant donné que ça sent
très fort je suis dit non mais désolé
mais je vous dis attendez la suite est
moins crade mais juste pour vous
là faut que je mette dans le contexte
donc c'est la pire situation que
pourquoi je suis traumatisé parce que
quand ça t'arrive ça t'as vraiment pas
envie que quelqu'un te vois et que ça se
sache que tu t'es chez nous alors qu'on
soit y'a rien de grave c'est juste et
malade ça arrive c'est pas grave
bref le lavabo change de couleur
littéralement et à droite dans cette
salle demain y avait une fenêtre mais
c'est une fenêtre tu ces troubles on
voit pas à travers j'avais peur que
quelqu'un ouvre cette fenêtre et fasse
hara tu t'es chier dessus tout cas un
peu improbable on va pas se mentir il
s'est passé pire bien pire il ya une
marque bien
collé contre la fenêtre hyper fort j'ai
clairement failli me ruffié dessus
vraiment j'ai eu peur j'ai sursauté ma
belle-mère donc là la copine de mon père
a deux filles et ses deux filles étaient
bien plus âgés que moi et elle sortait
le samedi soir elle revenait de boîte de
nuit un peu alcoolisé j'entends l'une
des deux dire mais enfin qui sait qui
dans la salle de bain cette heure-là ça
devrait être le cas on va lui dire
bonjour à tous je m'empresse de
verrouiller la porte de la salle de bain
la mecque j'ai jamais l'avait aussi vite
un vêtement de toute ma vie
il y avait de l'eau partout sur les murs
sur les serviettes elles viennent toquer
à la porte de la salle de bain tu sais
qu'elle a tu fais quoi mais laisse moi
tranquille mais laisse moi dans ma merde
à proprement parler est ce que je te
demande toi qu'est ce tu fais là bref à
ce moment là j'aurais adoré avoir un
post-it sous la main pour le glisser
sous la porte et marqué dessus je me
suis fait chier dessus
laissez moi tranquille merci mais
j'avais pas hostile alors d'une voix
fébrile je réponds je me sens pas très
bien mais tout va bien
mais quelle erreur il fallait juste et
je me brosser les dents mais demi soeur
étant bienveillante me proposent leur
aide tu as besoin de quelque chose tu
veux qu'on travaille une serviette on
attend devant la porte au cas où mais
cassez vous n'avez pas compris devant la
parcelle et moi sorti avec une odeur de
merde la [ __ ] bref après 20 minutes
elles vont dans leur chambre je
déverrouille la porte je sprinte jusqu'à
mon lit et j'oublie quelque chose qui
s'est passé peu avant sur ma course
retour vers mon lit je marche pour mon
venu hélas je n'ai plus le choix je dois
aller voir mes demi soeur en leur
demandant une serpillière car je ne
savais pas où elle était jeune et toi
alors le vomi je me recouche et dix ans
plus tard je vous raconte cette histoire
en vidéo
merci beaucoup c'est la halle et pour
tout ce qui touchait tu rejoues rebord
l'anecdote suivante les amis à quelque
chose dont j'ai profondément honte et
que j'aimerai à vous et m'excuser auprès
de la personne concernée comme vous le
savez très bien puisque j'arrête pas de
vous répéter à chaque vidéo temps ça m'a
marqué je jouais énormément à dofus
quand j'étais plus jeune
dofus je le rappelle est un rpg donc le
but c'est de passer des niveaux d'avoir
les meilleurs équipements d'avoir de
l'argent pour acheter les meilleurs
équipements tout ça tout ça mais le
petit lucas qu'à dix ans bah il veut
gruger le système
il veut pas en chie et lui il veut que
les gens lui donne des choses au moment
de créer mon personnage je choisis un
personnage féminin et je choisis aussi à
ce moment présent de devenir une fille
vraiment j'avais un dédoublement de la
personnalité quand je jouais j'étais
lucie et quand je ne jouais plus j'étais
nuque
mais attention quand je dis de venir lui
si c'est vraiment tout ce que ça
implique c'est que j'écrivais de la même
manière je faisais les mêmes choses
calmer d'hab je vous ai copiés je
mettais des petit smiley
en fin de phrase je faisais gaffe à
faire pour qu'une faute d'orthographe
alors que j'étais nul à chier en
orthographe je faisais genre je savais
pas des trucs évident que les gars on
trouve ça mignon et mof quelque chose
peut-être dans l'espoir d'avoir mon
numéro je sais pas j'étais diabolique
très rapidement je rencontre un confrère
ecaflip lui à vingt personnes au
masculin
donc je me suis dit ok c'est un mec là
est ce qu on va jouer de nos charme qui
n'existe pas dans la vraie vie pour
essayer d'avoir du minerai et de
l'argent a ajouté denis château j'étais
la petite mais je tout de puces bref je
lui parlais ils me donnent du fer sympa
il m'emmène xp encore plus sympa ils me
donnent de l'équipement colossalement
sympa et tout ce petit cinéma dure
pendant plusieurs semaines même moi je
commence à m'attacher aux mecs bon
c'était avant l'histoire des post it et
d'audrey a donc je me mets à douter je
me dis [ __ ] ça se trouve en fait
j'aime les hommes mais non j'ai aimé
tout simplement le pouvoir à 10 ans en
plus de jouer à dofus ensemble le but
principal de notre interaction à la base
la personne veut que l'on parle sur msn
/ msm la personne mais ça ou webcam est
en fait c'était une fille c'était une
fille lesbienne et comme je faisais
passer pour une meuf
eh ben elle était tombée un peu
amoureuse de moi eh mec je m'en voulais
tellement je savais plus quoi faire
j'avais 10 ou 11 ans donc c'était
vraiment longtemps mais ça m'a fait trop
mal au coeur et commence à me raconter
ces problèmes je commençais à l'aider à
les résoudre
j'étais impliqué dans sa vie vraiment
j'avais téléchargé un logiciel qui
permettait de passer des vidéos comme si
tu avais une webcam en fait donc je
mettais des vidéos de filles normales
pas dès funérailles on sait pas quoi
mais pour qu'elles croient que c'était
moi en fait sur ces vidéos là et elle y
croyait de fouet c'est juste en fait je
m'enfonçais dans mon mensonge parce que
je voulais pas faire de mal à cette
personne
écoutez un jour je me rattrape je veux
prendre conscience du tout ça et je veux
que ça cesse
alors je donne rendez vous au dessus
d'eux abda strübin et je lui dit écoute
je suis désolé mais en vrai je veux
arrêter dofus au le mec il a pas de
couilles il n'ose pas lui dire et là
elle me répond ah non c'était trop cool
de jouer avec toi
dommage mais bon pas grave tant qu'on
continue de se parler sur msn a mais on
pourra pas non plus en fait je pars à
l'étranger pour plusieurs années et je
n'aurais pas internet excuses mais
comment je vais faire moi sans toi
j'appuie alors sur la touche echap et
lucie
tu me réponds plus je clique alors sur
se déconnecter puis je vais sur la
vaisselle je la supprime je n'ai jamais
parlé
je suis désolé je sais pas qui tu es je
sais pas si tu vas bien ou pas mais
j'étais jeune j'étais con et surtout je
voulais du pouvoir dans dofus
je voulais gagner mes duels aériens de
ce métier au travers de ma route ne fait
jamais ça c'est débile on sent pas non
mais les gens s'attachent même
virtuellement et job je me rendais pas
compte à cette époque là alors soyez pas
des groupes qui ont faites pas comme moi
parce que ça a dû vraiment la blesser
sassou il en a souffert pendant grave
longtemps ou alors ça se trouve grâce à
ça elle s'est confiée à quelqu'un
d'autre et c'est devenu sa copine et
elles sont très heureuses et se sont
mariés même peut-être
j'espère les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo les anecdotes de squeeze deux
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu si ce cadre
était belle mais comme d'habitude
j'adore raconter des anecdotes ça me
fait rire c'est d'être au bon souvenir
même quand c'est un truc douloureux mais
avec le temps ça devient un truc rigolo
comme la dernière fois hésitez pas à
nous dire en commentaire les détruit qui
vous sont arrivés si vous avez des
anecdotes comme ça croustillantes
racontez nous la plus croustillante dans
les commentaires et surtout racontez
nous comment ça s'est passé la première
fois vous avez fait un bisou à une fille
moi je veux savoir c'est rigolo c'est
tellement de pression et tout quand tu
es jeune de faire ça que ça donne sur
des histoires amusantes en général ou
alors il ya que moi qui étais un [ __ ]
de looser a créé sur des post-it et tous
les autres ça s'est bien passé je sais
pas si vous êtes un post-it il vous
regardez cette vidéo je vous aime aulas
à celle m'a sauvé la vie jouera bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo au ballon
prisonnier
[Musique]